this is jocko podcast number 264
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
and also joining us tonight is dave
burke good evening dave
good evening so why is dave burke
joining us well there could be a
multitude of reasons but one of my
favorite reasons
is when the marine corps releases a new
doctrinal publication
which they just did it came out on
december 16
2020 and as soon as it came out
i sent dave a text and said hey there's
a new
pub out and he texts me back tell me
when we're recording a podcast on it
so here we are now you're gonna see
as we dive into this that if you know
the way broadly you see it in all things
and there was a sub
context of this manual that came to my
mind
almost as soon as i started reading it
but i couldn't quite
put my finger on it
and it took me about 10 pages deep
before i realized what this
thing was floating around in my head
and what i was seeing
underneath the surface which this this
publication
marine corps doctrinal publication one
tack for
the title of it is competing
but there's something just underneath
the surface of competing that i
saw throughout and i saw it almost
immediately but it took me
it took me a little longer than i would
have liked to identify
which is a bummer but it happened so
what was i seeing
underneath competing what i was seeing
was influencing
and as soon as i identified that
correlation
i i kept seeing it and and we'll share
with you today
not just the aspects of competing with
others but how this
continuum of competition reflects
the continuum of influence
and of course if you better understand
both of them you will be able to do
both of these things better you'll not
only get better at competing against
your enemy or against your rival
but you'll also become better at leading
leading the teammates you have inside
your own
organization so with that
let's get to it the marine corps
doctrinal
publication one tack for competing
and it starts off with a forward and in
the forward
it says this western conceptions
of the international struggle among
nations and other political actors
often use binary war or peace labels to
describe
it the actual truth is more complicated
so
out of the gate we're already getting
somewhere out of the gate we have to
recognize
that you can be competing with someone
but you're not at war with them
and there's an infinite degree of gray
area
in there and guess what
right out of the gate that's what struck
me right out of the gate guess what when
you're influencing someone
there's a whole degree
of levels of
pressure that you can exert
to go from influencing because let's
face it if i put a gun to your head
is that influence yes yes it is
so influence and competing very very
similar continuing on actors on the
world stage are always trying to create
a relative advantage for themselves and
for their group
sometimes this maneuvering leads to
violence but the use of violence to
achieve goals
is more often the exception than the
rule
now here's here's where this
again if i'm trying to influence
echo charles there's levels of influence
could one of those levels be
a double leg takedown yes and grounding
pounds yes it could we
how often does that happen i mean how
often do people
physically fight not very often when you
when you think of all the human
interactions that we have where we're
trying to influence
each other or trying to compete with
each other see it's a weird thing though
because
on the one side you've got competition
on the other side you've got influence
and the the continuum of how you apply
these pressures are
all over the place uh so it continues on
instead most
actors use other means in their
competitive interactions right
to achieve their goals so we're not
looking to go to war
the competition continuum encompasses
all of these efforts including the use
of violence
okay so there you go
continues on and by the way
this idea of competitive interactions
and influence interactions this is
what's happening
this is what is happening right when
we're
interacting so many of the interactions
that we have with people
are either competitive or their
influence right we're
constantly trying to get someone to do
something get someone to come on our
side get someone to
give us the support that we need get
them to move in this direction that's
what
people are doing
continuing on there are several reasons
for explaining the competition continuum
to
marines the first is to make them aware
that from recruitment to retirement they
are an integral part
of the nation's strategic competition
with other actors
marines are always competing even when
they are not fighting in combat
so this is something to think about as a
person
as a leader as a leader you're always
influencing
even when you're not standing up in
front of the troops giving a speech
about where you're going or what the
strategic
even then even when you're sitting down
to eat ciao
guess what you're doing you're
influencing
you're competing this is always
happening
then it rolls into this when you
understand those things it says next
understanding unleashes creativity
the marine corps coming at you with
unleashing creativity
right when you go to art school do you
think they say well listen the goal of
this art school is to get you to unleash
your creativity
no the marine corps will say that and
isn't it interesting we're two
paragraphs in and we're talking about
the creative aspects of competition
and then hand in hand with that the
creative aspects of influence
carrying on once marines understand the
nature and form of competition their
innovative spirit will lead to the
development
of new kinds of competition new kinds of
competitive advantages
finally this publication expands the
discussion on how and where
marines fit into the continuum and where
to look
for their natural partners in
competition
by design this is a small book
with a construction that parallels
marine corps doctrinal publication
one war fighting which is one of the
first publications we
covered on this podcast it is not
intended as a reference manual but it is
designed to be read from cover to cover
this publication does not contain
specific techniques or procedures we
should adopt
rather it provides broad guidance in the
form of concepts with illustrations
intended to stimulate thinking
and encourage additional learning it
requires judgment in application
this is uh this is the way i like to
learn
this is the way i like to teach so when
i and the really easy thing to talk
about is
jiu jitsu right you want to be able to
teach it the advantage of this
broad position is this the thing you
need to do when you're in this situation
broadly
is win this underhook or whatever
whatever the thing is
and that's what this book is it's not
like hey here's in this situation
it's not formulaic
continuing on we live in a time of
renewed great power
competition in an era of exponential
technological and social change
marines enjoy a rich heritage of
advancing our nation's interests in
these kinds of struggles
as we look to the future we must ensure
today's and tomorrow's marines do the
same
like maneuver warfare and just that
statement followed by anything kind of
warms my heart
like maneuver warfare competing is a way
of thinking it's a way of
thinking and man dave i kind of went
berserk on like decentralized command as
a way of thinking not too long ago
right i mean i went on ef online i would
spend two or three days
of the of the sessions talking about
decentralized command
as a way of thinking and it's so
interesting how much that changes your
perspective about something
when you think of it not in a linear way
like oh this is what you're going to do
but this is the entire way of thinking
it's like
saying oh when you fight someone
you can get them to the ground and you
can grapple with them
instead of punching them that's just a
whole new way of thinking
you don't even know one single move
about it but you know this idea that you
can then utilize
we must understand the importance of
strategic competition
and the essential role marines play in
it for our
nation only i missed this line it says
we
all need to read study and debate this
publication with our fellow marines
you chimed in on that one didn't you
dave yeah what do you like about that
i like that i like the explanation of
this i went through the same thing
initially when i was kind of
looking at this there was parts of it
that i was thinking it was gonna be like
war fighting
but it had this kind of intellectual
there's a thought process thing this
idea that what he's saying the guy in
charge of the marine corps
you need to go out there and debate this
and think about this and he's using
words like creativity and intellect
those those have a those are not the
words you would normally think of when
you think of the marine corps
creativity intellectual and debate those
are just not the things you'd think of
and those are things he's saying that
you need to do and what i really like
about it
is we think of the marine corps we think
of the military in general and then we
think of the marine corps of course
of being this hierarchy that is just
as strict as you can imagine and here's
a document and and
general david h berger to comment on the
marine corps is saying the purpose of
this
document is to make you debate not to
not to just obey what it says
but to make you debate we want you to
think
that's a beautiful thing so there we are
we are now done with the forward
let's get into what the book actually
says
the nature of competition chapter one
total
war and perfect peace rarely exist in
practice
instead they are the extremes between
which
exist the relations among most political
groups
this range includes routine economic
competition
more or less permanent political or
ideological tension
and occasional crisis among groups
so what's that that's from that's from
warfighting the the marine corps manual
number one
and by the way these things that we're
talking about
tensions competition not not violent
competition but just competition where
do those things exist
they exist sure they exist between
countries but guess where else they
exist they
exist between companies and guess where
else they exist
between departments inside of companies
and guess where they exist
between people inside of departments
inside of companies
inside your family there's competition
going on
these words from the marine corps war
fighting philosophy framed the idea of
competition for marines
they also serve as a springboard for
marines to think about how they can
contribute to winning the nation's
competitions
including the ones taking place below
the threshold of violence
which by the way is 99.999 percent
of competitions violence
is rare and when we get into influence
look it's almost cheesy
for me to talk about influence of like
well i could put if i put a gun to your
head or i
beat you with a baseball bat to get you
to do what i want you to do
right that's that's that's a rare form
of influence that doesn't happen all the
time
but there's a threat there is a
threshold of violence and i think as we
talk about it and i haven't fully
i haven't fully hashed out these ideas
in my head but there's a transition time
when it when when you're influencing
there's a transition time
when you go from indirect to direct form
of influencing there's a transition that
you cross
and it's not quite a threshold of
violence but there's a there's a
transition that takes place
and i think we'll find some comparisons
to it in here but i think about that all
the time
how how much at what point do you go
from indirect to direct
and it's funny we we had somebody on ef
online the other day
and this type of question came up
but what i was explaining was the the
escalation of counseling right and you
start off by saying hey bro
are you good you know you're okay and
then it goes to like hey this is a
problem and then go say hey i'm gonna
write you up and then you get written up
and
and then you fire somebody if you have
to
and i'm sitting there talking to go you
know how many times
in my life i made it past the lowest
level of escalation and counseling
the times that i said hey dave it
doesn't look like the gear was ready in
time and dave was like dude sorry
we lay blah blah blah and it never
happens again that's 97
there's another two percent where it was
like hey
bro that's the second time we almost
missed our movement because the gear
wasn't ready
do you need help no i got it and it
never happens again that's another two
percent now we're at 99
there's another point whatever percent
where i actually had to write something
up and there's point zero zero whatever
where i had to take you know action to
fire somebody or get rid of them
the same thing as you go through this
escalation of war
you should be able to get people to do
what you want them to do
through non-war
without breaking the threshold of
violence
continuing on competition happens
constantly in many forms amongst nations
of the world in diplomatic informational
military and economic arenas
rivals often challenge each other
in one of them while they cooperate in a
different one no
that's good to know isn't it isn't it
good to know that we can be competing in
one thing and cooperating in something
else simultaneously
competitors include a wide range of
political actors from nation states to
groups
organized around a single cause while
discussion below will
often refer to state versus state
rivalries in most cases the ideas
apply equally to challenges with
non-state actors
competition in various forms among
various different actors is the norm in
international relations
so that's great that they're talking
about international relations and
we're talking about these i keep
throwing all these percentages out today
is that a good thing i don't think it's
a good
thing it's a little question it's
questionable is anyone going to be able
to check me on my 97
facts no all right well
i'm gonna estimate that a vast majority
of people that are listening to this
podcast
are not engaged at a policy level
with interstate rivalries
so what's important to recognize is that
everything that we're talking about
doesn't only apply to this country
versus that country
it applies everywhere continuing on the
marine corps participates
in the competitions of the united states
in many ways foremost among them
is to fight and win our nation's battles
and be ready to do so at all times
and then it says this war itself is a
special kind of competition
which is a classic line right uh
to say that war itself is a special kind
of competition
so we salute the marine corps for that
statement because it certainly is
a special type of competition how it
fits in the overall continuum will be
explored in detail
the very existence of the marine corps
is a competitive act
as it signals to potential rivals that
there are vital interests
our nations will go to war to protect
and that those of a maritime nature are
important enough that we have invested
in a dedicated naval expeditionary force
to protect them
so that's a big statement and and one
thing that i love about this
entire manual is this entire manual
written by the marine corps and i just
want you to pay attention to this and
you kind of have to know what's going on
between all the different services
you've got the army navy air force
marines and coast guard
and all of them are in competition at
all times
and not just hey our planes are better
than yours and our pilots are better not
no not that comp
they're competing for money for money
and so that i'm i hate to do this to
marine corps because i do love the
marine corps
but there are just so many maneuvers in
this book
that that if you read it you go well we
better take care of the marine corps we
better give them a little edge and
that's one of those lines right there
vital interest in our nation just in
case you care about the ocean
just in case you care about the ocean
you might want a marine corps they get
that in there
but what's interesting about this is the
very existence of the marine corps
is a competitive act so how many things
do you do
or have or say that just just
being there is a competitive act go a to
your point i mean look
that's i think it's cool the marine
corps wrote this i'm stoked that it's a
marine corps pub i was a marine
but just like what you said you could
change the words marine corps you could
put any word you want in there
the existence of the military you just
made a connection to family this idea of
competition
so when when i was looking at this at
first not knowing what to expect
the connection that i was making of when
they're talking about competing the
first thing is
competition doesn't have to be a bad
thing that word shouldn't mean oh that
means conflict and we're fighting that
isn't what it means and it doesn't have
to be about
two nations going to war it doesn't even
have to be about the marine corps and
the fact that marine corps wrote it is
cool that's not the point
and something else that you've been
talking about a lot
lately and i've been i've been i've been
stealing it
you've been talking a lot about
alignment and
when there's conflict in an organization
we see this at companies we work with
all the time
what you need to do is find alignment
and the thing i was just thinking in
that first couple of sentences is
competition the more aligned you and i
are the healthier
the competition is meaning the less
likely
the outcome is going to be some sort of
conflict or a fight if we're aligned
really aligned we might be competing all
the time just to make each other better
just do a better job for our clients
whatever it is
and the likelihood of you and i
competing and we might be competing
every day
the likelihood of uni competing turning
it into a conflict is almost zero
now if we are highly misaligned
misaligned then that competition has
the potential of the outcome being much
different but competition by itself
where it applies and what it means five
minutes into it you're talking family
so there's a connection here that is way
deeper than it that first couple of
sentences at face values i'm looking oh
the marine corps public competition is
going to be cool
there's a lot more to it it doesn't have
to be about the marine corps as you're
listening to it either
yeah one of the notes that i that i took
down um
early on when i when i started talking
about 99
the note that i took down when i was
reading it for the first time
was 99 of the time
you don't have to resort to violence
because you can find alignment because
as long as you can find
and you've heard me say that on ef
online if you can find alignment well
then
we can work together if you and i are
aligned if you and i are not aligned on
48 different things that are lower level
things but we're aligned at the most
important thing
we're good we're good and the example of
that when i bring up with companies
is hey you know jocko and dave can't get
along
oh okay well they can't get along about
what well dave wants to invest in that
jackal wants to invest in that dave
wants to move here jocko wants to move
there
okay so they can't get along okay well
let's ask this question
do dave and jocko who work at the same
company do they want the company to make
money
yes do they want to be able to serve
their customers yes
if we can get aligned on those things
then the rest of it is just figuring out
the details
and the if if we if you do what you were
just talking about if the more you think
in decentralized command the more you
think
in in commander's intent the more you
think strategically the less you care
about those details you go oh wait oh
you want the same thing
dude go do whatever you want let me know
how i can help because then i think
oh oh none of those details matter at
all because you want
what i want and if i can just check my
ego and go oh oh you know what
dude yeah go do that can i back you up
give me a call if i can help you
the competition part or the conflict
part goes away
and it allows you to accomplish so many
more things if you
think in decentralized command rather
than just the action of oh well i'm a
leader
i have to push some decisions down to my
next layer down that's the
the actions of decentralized command
you're talking about thinking a
decentralized command
that's what lets you not worry about all
those details yeah and by the way
if i want dave to be at point a
and d i know that dave knows to go to
point a
i don't care how he gets there but
what's important is
that allows me to look
forward to look to the next point to
look to point b or c
or d because i'm not worried about how
dave's gonna get here he's gonna get
there and if he needs some help he knows
to call me cool
no factor
the capabilities the marine corps
generates in preparation for battle are
also competitive as these capabilities
are what deter
a potential rival from selecting a
course of action above the
threshold of violence so what they're
saying there what the united states
marine corps is saying there
is even if you want peace more than
anything else you better have a marine
corps
you better have a marine corps to deter
provincial potential rival from
selecting a course of action
that's violent if you want peace you
better have a marine corps
are they going to be mad at me for
deciphering all this go easy
[Laughter]
god bless them the marine corps however
does not win our nation's competitions
alone
in fact the marine corps is most likely
to support or contribute to advancing
u.s interests as
a part of a much larger competitive
strategy the marine corps
can do a great deal to help the united
states compete successfully but it will
do
so as part of a larger national effort
that extends well beyond military
instrument national power so the marine
corps has to cover and move with all the
other
elements of the military we're team
players yeah
not just the military but the state
department and the economy and
everything else the marine corps despite
looking after themselves a little bit
with this manual
they are team players from recruitment
to retirement marines have the potential
to help the nation compete and
successful
successfully in many ways it starts with
the right mindset one that recognizes
marine corps top priorities to win
battles
while also recognizing that war and
warfare are segments of a larger
spectrum
known as the competition continuum
marines need to be clear-eyed about this
spectrum
even when the marines are not at war one
of its many forms in one of its many
forms
they are still in a state of competition
while demonstrating the ability to fight
and win wars is crucial for deterrence a
successful foreign policy will avoid
wars
especially against great power rivals
whenever possible great
competition continuum
this whole thing it escalates
competition is a fundamental aspect of
international relations
as state and on state actors seek to
protect and advance their own interests
they continually compete for the
advantage okay so that's what
everyone is doing am i paranoid
i might be i might be i might be a
little bit paranoid
people are competing people are
maneuvering and that's what we're doing
right that's what that other company's
doing that's what that other department
is doing that's what that other country
is doing
they're maneuvering what are they doing
that for they're doing it to
further their own interests now
going back to the idea of alignment this
also falls into agendas
right because if dave is trying to make
some maneuver inside of our company and
i'm trying to make some maneuver inside
of our company
as long as those maneuvers still get us
to the point we want to go to
i don't care we're good with it we're
good with it we're fine
so people trying to advance their own
their
own interests most of the time
is fine as long as they're not
undercutting
the strategic goals that we have
but people are always competing they're
always making that little move
some people a little bit more obvious
than others
and here's what you gotta watch out for
what you gotta watch out for is when
people
have an agenda that helps them but it
doesn't
move you in your strategic direction
that's what you're watching out for
what you're watching out for is when
dave and his department hey it's great
when dave and his department are trying
to get money so they can get more funds
so they can hire more people so they can
grow so they can get
a bigger production and they can move us
toward the strategic goal of growing our
business
that's all good dave is literally
competing to get more
money for his department so he can grow
his department which will help him
create more income so our whole business
moves forward that's great
but there's a chance that dave wants to
you know set up uh he wants to set up a
an office in happens to be
0.2 miles down the road from his house
happens to be in a building that he owns
happens to want to charge a certain
amount of rent we don't need
anything in that area but he's doing it
for himself
that's what we got to watch out for and
i'll tell you
when you're making those maneuvers for
yourself
everybody sees it you think you're smart
you think you're getting away with it
you think no one notices you think
you think oh you know what well i do own
the building but it's really a great
spot
nobody believes you nobody believes you
so don't do it don't do things
for yourself interests that undermine
that aren't aligned with the strategic
goal whenever i get somebody that
i can't figure out quite why they're
doing what they're doing
well dave what do you mean why would
explain to me why you want this building
there again why you want to put an
office there
well i'm telling you there's a really a
good market and
dave we we're already in that market we
can control this other area yeah but
it's uh
you know i think it'd be really good for
the company okay well tell me it would
be good well
you know we could we could have some
offices there i don't know i understand
what what you want to do
why is it good so when i when we can't
when i can't
understand why it is you want to do
something
there's a chance i need to say wait a
second
is dave doing this for some reason
some agenda that is not for the good of
the organization
is he competing against
what we're doing because that's a
problem
and i'll see through it every single
time and so will everybody else
it's so obvious man it's so obvious
nations and other political actors
pursue their interests constantly
and in a variety of ways competition
results
when the interests of one political
group interact in some way with another
group these interactions take place in a
dynamic environment each
move an actor makes towards fulfilling
an interest changes that ecosystem
any interaction of interests changes the
situation as well so what does that mean
we got to track that ooda loop
right because every move you make or
every move your competitor makes makes
everything a little bit different
competitions are often labeled as zero
sum
or positive sum the zero-sum rivalry
means that if one group achieves its
goal
then the rival group cannot achieve its
own a good example of zero-sum
competition is when two nations struggle
over the ownership of an island
in most cases only one of them can
physically control it at a time
positive sum means that more than one
group can make progress towards
fulfilling interests
or achieving goals at the same time for
example two nations may compete
economically but both may see their
gross domestic product
increase simultaneously that's
what i think we commonly refer to as a
win-win situation
which i love which i love i prefer
we don't want to do zero sum we want to
say oh i don't want to i don't want to
do something to dave's division that
shuts his division down i want him to
win i want us
i need to win it's fine positive
why is it positive
why is it positive it's positive because
i'm not
just thinking tactically i'm thinking
strategically
and if what i do right now is burn dave
and burn his
efforts to the ground what is dave gonna
do
in two years in five years or in ten
years he's coming back at me
now are there times when you have to do
squirt earth policy yes there are
most of the time you don't have to most
of the time it's better to build
than destroy
competition manifests itself in several
ways such as when one actor attempts to
impose
its will on the other another way is
when one actor
acts to frustrate another's plans
preventing them from achieving their
goals
think of when these little things happen
to you think of when you feel that
someone like wait a second why is echo
why is this another roadblock why does
that go why hasn't he done this little
task yet what's going on
well guess what sabotage is what's going
on trying to frustrate the goals
both of these mainly apply to zero-sum
struggles in a positive sum
example two economic rivals will try to
best each other
like when they try to increase their
market share in a particular industry at
the expense of their rival while both of
their economies grow so that's fine
competition especially at the
nation-state level
is complex and it is systemic for
example auto manufacturers in the united
states compete with rival companies
isn't this interesting dave as often as
we talk to businesses
and i've also i've often well i've not
often but i've talked about this before
what came first the military learning
from industry or industry learning from
the military because it goes back and
forth it's like a continuous cycle
so here we are in the marine corps
manual that they just released and what
do they use for an example not a war
example
they use a business example
the marine corps uses a business example
for example
auto manufacturers in the united states
compete with rival companies in the
european union and japan but this does
not mean the us government is also in
direct competition with these
governments
even though the auto manufacturers are
based in their respective
territories indirectly the auto
manufacturers may lobby their
governments asking them to take actions
that favor their company in the global
competition for auto sales
the individual actors are intertwined
and interact with each other in many
different ways
the details of this brief example are
less important
than it is for marines to understand so
there's an example but here's what you
got to understand strategic competition
among international political actors is
multi-layered and networked
each competitor consists of many parts
that interact in complex ways
as we see from these examples
competition and cooperation
can co-exist and competition does not
need to lead to conflict
so there's all so many factors at play
and that's on a national level but
there's so many factors at play in the
way you talk to someone else
the way you treat somebody else and the
facial expressions that you make now we
get into
the continuum
when i was a tradet training people
i would start off by giving them a
problem
and then a little bit of space to work
through that problem then another
problem and then a little bit of space
to work
and physical space like okay there's a
problem that's gonna happen before you
get to the target then there's gonna be
a problem on target then there's gonna
be a problem as you leave the target
then there's gonna be a problem as
you're at your extract point
and so they're separated by time and
space so i
remember telling the leadership of this
one task and i said
now i go that did you did a pretty good
job
but what you're gonna see happen now is
i am going to compress the time space
continuum that these problems occur
meaning they're going to occur at the
same time in the same location
and that causes problems so the
continuum that we're talking about here
this is no perfect model to use there is
no perfect model to use in explaining
the competition continuum
the many feedback loops it contains make
it very complex so models will omit some
details however the models are useful
because they help explain specific
concepts and assist marines in building
their own
visual age visualization of the
continuum so they have this
basically a line on the one on the one
far side is pure peace the other
far side is total war
so it starts with pure peace then it
goes to economic competition
classic diplomacy and geopolitics so
that's sort of like hey we're at peace
but oh
wait we're not quite at peace anymore
now we're moving to economic competition
maybe some classic diplomacy some
geopolitics
and then you get into this area called
political warfare
at the at the far end of economic
competition is political warfare meaning
i'm putting tariffs on you
so now we're getting more aggressive
then you get to this area called the
gray zone which is now
maybe its sanctions and now we're being
really aggressive
then you get to a hybrid war
and then you get to the threat of
violence
and then you get to use of violence
there's a threshold
and once you get past the threshold of
violence you can go further right which
is conventional war
okay we're gonna go to war we're gonna
have your tanks against my tanks and
your airplanes against my plants
and then we get to total war which is
whatever it takes to survive and win
no mercy of any kind
so that's a linear model of this there's
also a circular model that they have and
by the way you can get this
this manual you can just go on the
google uh
you know one tac four competing and
you'll find it and you can download it
print it what's up what's
an example of total war and
versus conventional war like which war
was like a total war
the closest i would say we got is world
war ii
to total to total war but we were still
let's face it we were still following
the geneva convention right but imagine
if
things were so bad that you just were
we're just kidding let's just outright
just kill destroy and chemical weapons
and
just total war i mean in in world war ii
you know we drop we dropped the atom
bomb yeah that's
that's freaking straight that's just
total war right you're you're killing
everyone
yeah we firebombed dresden 250 000
civilians
or 250 000 people many civilians dead
an entire city destroyed go google
dresden before and after
i mean it's not quite as shocking as
hiroshima nagasaki before and after but
it's complete and utter devastation it's
as much devastation as we could possibly
cause with the weapons we had at hand um
is there like a scenario where like
one side is that total war and the other
side it's like hey we're gonna keep this
kind of conventional
i mean it kind of seems like right like
certain we'll say groups whether it be
nations whatever have a certain
philosophy
i would say that yeah i mean i think we
i don't know if we could get to
where someone was at total war i mean i
think the japanese were pretty close i
think the nazis were pretty close
to total war they would do whatever they
you know they do whatever they could
but even even um yeah
they even they had limits yeah
you know but i mean let's face it they
were close
they were close i mean japan was doing
their best to develop chemical and
biological weapons that they could use
that they were on that path and would if
they had gotten them you think they
would have done it
i'm gonna say affirmative so they might
have been a total war
you know you can maybe look at some of
these some of these non-state actors
right
i mean isis was isis at total war they
don't have didn't have the capabilities
or the means but if they had
the opportunity to just kill
indiscriminately kill as many people as
they possibly could would they yeah
probably
yeah that's what i mean so like yeah
these groups like yeah they don't have
the
physical capability but that was their
approach like that they
in their mind
the next thing was talking about a
circular model a circular model shows
conflict above violence threshold
and competition below it and they kind
of go
through these one of the things that
brings up here one of the actors could
be deterred
so you might think you're going towards
war but then you get deterred
uh the threat of violence could have
been significant
leverage and other rivals decided you
know what i don't want none of this
tension recedes negotiations of some
kind may have succeeded
bringing the actors back from the
threshold of violence these are all
things that
think about uh uh for you as a bouncer
right think about as you approach a
level of
like there's a threshold of violence
where someone's taking a swing think
about all the little things
that could happen that could de-escalate
that yeah you know maybe it's
negotiation hey look man you just need
to get out of here maybe it's hey we're
calling the cops
how often does that one work pretty
often yeah right
yeah that there's a when you whatever
you go through this training
and the that's part of it that whole
thing that escalation of force right and
there's like
many thresholds you know like first it's
like straight up friendly
and the better are we gonna get
roadhouse quotes in here oh yeah
well in roadhouse they do kind of go
over it a little bit
yeah sorry the training you went through
man i'm having some like real positive
flashbacks about
or images of you and and and what's his
name bodhi
no dalton oh he's from uh bodies from
point breaks yeah which i respect by the
way
so yeah well in a way yeah because okay
so dalton that wasn't really a training
that was more of a lecture
and that was a very specific philosophy
which was cool i dig it whatever so
there's different philosophies in the
with i would say the continuum of
violence
it's where bounces go yes spectrum of
the continuum
yeah fully but each yeah each level has
like a little threshold like i said
but yes the most prominent one is like
yeah and it's kind of the same thing it
reflects that total war kind of
situation
where you know like let's go to that end
part of the spectrum right you go
like total war is like we don't have
time for the police to come we gotta
like we gotta act
because this person is violent towards
us or whatever and then it's a
straight-up fight
where you can expect like laws to be
broken
within that fight kind of thing and then
there's like one before where it's like
okay we gotta like put put our hands on
him we gotta whether it be restrain them
or whatever
but we're we're not trying to be violent
towards this person we have to use what
they used to call it the minimum force
necessary
i use that term all the time yeah
minimum force required or minimal force
necessary
yeah i mean i think a more appropriate
term would be you know
uh we'll say an appropriate amount of
force
okay you know because the minimum i
don't know there's just a lot of wiggle
room for
some some stuff to not go right for us
you know for the good guys yeah yeah
busted um you know but that's like the
conventional war kind of scenario you
know
and by the way you're telling the police
that the minimum force was working
the minimum force required was what was
used yes even though you
may have used the approach appropriately
so there's maybe a little linguistics
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu happening
yes because we want to you know we don't
want to see echo charles locked up
no back in the day no you don't but i
mean you could it could be argued that
they're the same thing you know where
it's like an appropriate amount of force
meaning like you're not abusing this guy
no matter how much he's verbally
whatever whatever trunk or whatever but
yeah it's
but there is that convince those rules
like yeah put your hands on them use
force
knock them out if you have to you know
you like you can do these kind of things
but you can't be just like violating all
kinds of you know
situations because it's not total war
it's not total war
there's a line in here it says there are
many possibilities on how
rivals can turn away from the violence
threshold and return to steady-state
competition
and i made a note here for myself
that crossing that line
is almost always
a tactical move a tactical meaning
it is an immediate it's solving this
immediate problem but it is
seldom a strategic move because think
about it when
if you're in the street and you get into
a fight you want to do everything you
can to avoid that fight
and if you have to engage in that fight
it's almost guaranteed to be a tactical
win
and a strategic loss now you got to go
to jail now you got to pay this guy
money now you got to get arrested now
you got cuts on your hands
you got all these little problems and it
would have been
infinitely better to have just said you
know what this guy's not worth it or
whatever you walk away
from a leadership perspective it is
almost always almost always
if you cross if you cross the line and
there's some
gap but indirect when you go from from
indirect
influence to direct it's
almost always attac it might be attacked
to win it's going to be a strategic loss
so the minute i say you know what dave
i'm not talking about this anymore
here's what you're going to do
that's almost guaranteed to be a
tactical win because you're going to go
and execute whatever i told you to do
but guess what strategically i just took
a step back i took a strategic hit i'm
not saying i can't recover from it
but strategically it's a negative so we
have to be careful of that
it says here we also see that sometimes
the threshold is crossed for a short
time only to jump back down
into a state of competition below the
violence threshold that's great
just as described above note that
deterrence is not the only thing that
causes a movement in this model a
competitor could also move
below the violence threshold again if he
achieves its goals
negotiated a bargain uh a thoughtful
review of this model shows it as many
uses so
always look to not cross that
that threshold from violence into
violence or into direct
orders if you're in a leadership
position and
you use direct orders you use your rank
to influence bad
however make no mistake that the above
models simply offer us different views
to consider and this is the circular and
the linear model
they offer different views on how to
consider as we study strategic
competition
all of the terms we use including
conflict competition violence and even
war are part of an
organic whole all of these terms reside
on a single continuum that describes the
relationship
between and among states in
international relations
but it's not just states i just have to
remind you this it's different divisions
inside your company
it's different personalities inside your
team
there's all these levels on this
continuum
these political actors use activities at
various points in the continuum
to advance their interests and also
to set conditions to make it easier for
them to achieve their interest in the
future
this behavior is like a judo competition
when a competitor constantly tries to
put the opponent
off balance sometimes through the
application of violence sometimes
by moving a position of advantage
or moving to a position of advantage war
itself is an integral part of this
continuum
so that's that's judo right you you
every move is not war every move is a
setup a little setup here and then
you're looking for that e pull
here is here is
some of the work of the state
department's george
f kennan following world war ii
canon was the author of the famous long
telegram that described the
nature of the soviet union and alerted
decision makers to the emerging cold war
and the need for the us government to
organize itself for
political warfare and
here's what he wrote political warfare
is the logical application of klaus
wit's doctrine in a time of peace
in broadest definition political warfare
is the employment of all means of a
nation's command
at our nation's command short of war to
achieve its national objectives
that's george cannon that's what he
wrote and it says these opening words to
kennan's
paper were directed to the national
security council the paper advocated for
both
overt and covert means to compete
internationally short of using violence
in the cold war struggle that was just
beginning kenan stated that the united
states was handicapped by a belief
and this is why i had to include this
part because this is a mistake that we
make as people
cannon stated that the united states was
handicapped by a belief that there was
that there is a basic difference between
war and peace
to view war as a sort of sporting
context
contest outside the political context
so in america we just look like you're
either at war or you're not
he's like no you're competing all the
time
his work helped decision makers
understand ideas like political warfare
which have then helped the united states
build the capabilities successful to
compete in the cold war
yeah you're going to need more than
tanks and planes if you're going to win
yeah and there's a whole thing
that's happening so when it's happening
it's happening all the time and it's
happening all the time so when you're
in a leadership position guess what
there is
an infinite number of things that you
need to be
ready to do and doing to lead besides
war which is
shut up and do what i told you to do
kennen's diagnosis of the comp of the
competition significantly shaped the way
it unfolded across the whole
of the united states government in the
decades that followed this highlights
two important points for marines
the first is the importance of
accurately identifying the nature of
the competition one faces imagine that
competition
one faces you know i was dave caught me
on the end of a call with a
client and i was like we
need to be at war and i guess i always
refer to my clients as we
you know whenever i'm talking to one of
our clients it's we it's us totally like
we are at war with you i said we gotta
we gotta go to war with them but we
don't want them to know it
that means there's not gonna be any any
overt action it's all gonna be covert
here's some methodology we can do that
we went through some of these ways that
we could
go to war without going to war ways that
we could compete without going to war
that way it is understood the way that
it is
understood will affect the choices made
in how to pursue
the competition an accurate appreciation
will
increase the chances for success marines
have an important but supporting role in
strategic competition
this shapes the way we approach our
competitive efforts
so now we get into this section did you
have something i'm just thinking
you know making the connection to the
the conversations we have with our
clients or even just in any leadership
role
how often how often does my ego let me
jump to the conclusion if you're doing
something different than what i'm doing
that's a problem and i gotta attack it
like it's a problem and i gotta treat
you like now we're competitors as
opposed to hey you know what i need to i
would say i need to accurately identify
the nature of this situation which means
i got to look at and go oh
hang on why is jaco making this move why
is he doing that
and if i can figure that out if there
actually is the situation that you're at
the same company
more often than not there's going to be
a positive reason for that i just got to
figure that out
or i can just say oh that's not what i
would have done let's fight
and then we can compete with each other
and go at each other and
the the ability the the need to be able
to strategically understand
what is really going on and how often
your ego gets in the way go oh
well that's a problem giaco is doing
this that's a problem and now we're
fighting now we're competing and now
we're going at each other
instead of me just taking a little step
back going hey hey help this move you
just made to help me understand that oh
yeah i did this for these couple reasons
oh okay good to go so we're actually not
competing here we're on the same page
that is a when we talk about
people ask us questions all the time but
i'm having this problem this person that
person
almost always comes back to well what is
it that's really going on
and and you talk about climbing up the
ladder of alignment can you just find
where
what he's doing what you're doing
actually achieve the same end
or at least are heading in the same
direction yeah something that it's not
automatically
immediately a problem that you got to
now go to war over
uh next section and again my
salute to the marine corps for just even
having this thought
war is a special kind of competition
that's the name of this section our war
fighting philosophy informs us that war
is a violent clash of interest between
or among organized groups characterized
by the use of military force
war is fundamentally an interactive
social process
hold on
i've been studying war for a long time
i've never really thought of it as a
fundamentally interactive social process
but i guess we'll go with it
its essence is a violent struggle
between two hostile independent
and irreconcilable wills each trying to
impose itself
on the other that i agree with that to
me is
not really an interactive social process
that's a freaking scrap
war so what am i missing there
i i i guess what i'm missing there
is that there is this aspect that you
need to have
two elements that are
that are interacting
to have this to have a war take place i
mean it takes two to tango
right i guess i'm just picturing who of
the
six authors that got locked in a room to
write this club which
who was the guy that got that held onto
who was like no no no no
really i'm thinking i'm telling you it's
an interactive social process
and the other five are like fine just
put it in there whatever dude yeah wait
did we did colonel pogue
get his paws on this thing i don't know
well
who knows maybe they'll revise it maybe
someone will explain it to me
because because you can tell look when
you read these marine corps
field manuals they're so well written
they're so clean they don't leave things
in there that aren't
in there for a reason that's why i
question myself here i don't know what
i'm missing
um but it's just let at a minimum it's a
strange way to describe war
as an interactive social process
but we'll go with it wars character wars
character can take many forms from using
military force
to simply restore order during disaster
relief operations to completely
overturning the existing
order within a society war resides on
the competition continuum
above the threshold of violence from a
military perspective we
also call the points along this scale
above the threshold
various forms of armed conflict
there are many descriptors of the form
that war takes
such as insurgency hybrid conventional
when we think of competition in war the
main points
are to acknowledge that war is a
political act that uses violence to
achieve its aims
but is also part of a spectrum of other
competitive acts that do not use
violence
okay so war isn't just what's happening
on the battlefield it's everything else
as well
in the circular model of competition
conflict feeds back into competition
war sets the conditions for the
character of the
competition that follows it war is like
a violent move in judo conte in a judo
contest
it its use can put a competitor into
an advantageous position relative to the
opponent
okay those those things are pretty
straightforward
obviously had a judo player in the room
one of the six people that wrote this
thing
competition contains competition
contains many of the same attributes as
war ambiguity ambiguity
ambiguity sorry ambiguity competition
contains
many of the same attributes as war isn't
that interesting
ambiguity just like in war ambiguity
seems to be
everywhere we turn in competition
and i just did a kind of win off on on
ef online
about the fact that we don't know what's
going to happen
there's ambiguity in everything and yet
people will
people will just dig in and dave says
hey we should attack from the west and i
say no we should attack from the north
we don't know where the enemy is why am
i so
hostile towards dave because he wants to
attack from the west and i want to
attack from the north
i have no idea where the enemy is going
to be why am i digging in on that
because i'm an idiot and i let my ego
run it
as noted two groups may try to best each
other
in one area while they cooperate in
another which can make
the nature of the relationship between
them unclear the differences
among rivals often clouds the pictures
as well if the interests of two groups
collide but the interests of the first
group are vital
while those of the second group are a
lower priority there will be a mismatch
between how the two groups
view the competition
first thing about the the difference is
cloud the picture
for sure and that's why we always want
to understand what someone else's
perspective is
because otherwise we're looking at two
different things and we can't comprehend
how to come to some kind of a solution
and then this is an interesting one and
something you need to pay attention to
as a leader
you know someone comes to you and says
hey we really want to do this and to you
you're like ah
it's .00 it's a it's a rounding error on
our bottom line
whatever we don't need to do that
but man for whatever group that is that
might be the highest priority thing
they've gotten you're just throwing it
away
so pay attention to what the priorities
are and what priorities seem to you
might be different and not not just the
priorities
the importance how do you say that word
importance you said it correctly okay
the importance of
what the way somebody feels the level of
some
element is i think something super
important and echo doesn't think it's a
big deal
we're going to have a hard time
communicating and coming to a good
resolution that makes sense to both of
us
if he can understand oh this is really
important to jocko because of these
things
okay got it dave dave comes to me it's
critical that we get this
office building up in this area why is
that so important to dave oh because
dave lives two blocks away oh cool got
it
at least i understand that but it could
be that dave
has some big project that he's you know
company that's going to come on board
and blah blah then you could have a
really
important reason and if i don't
understand that or see that we're not
going to be able to connect and figure
things out
you talk about with kids all the time
when kids will come to you the problem
they'll
it'll sound like the end of the world
you look at them like dude this is this
is no big deal but actually to them it's
a huge deal huge deal
and the connection you can actually make
is just understanding oh i got it
this is a big deal to you let me
understand a little bit better no big
deal we can sort it out but
you make that connection even at that
level all the time at that level they
say
this is the end of the world for me and
in your mind like you're not going to
remember this in two months
yeah you know what's weird is we talk
about kids
that includes people that are 32 years
old that includes people that are 27
years old
right yeah when your world's falling
apart
you have to understand how important
things are to people and that's what
this is talking about
you know what's a bro you've been a
rounding error it seemed like a small
thing but what is that around me and
that's wrong it's like let's say
let's say echo charles was making 400
million dollars a year
and as they calculate all the money
there's 200
dollars they're like oh whatever like
it's just a little rounding here it's a
little tiny bit of money
in the big scheme of things all right so
if you came to me you're like hey i
really wanna
you know i really want some more money
for this and i'm like
whatever it's a rounding here we're not
doing that and you're
mad but it's something that was very
important to you
right my team's entire annual budget's
200 grand and this
my entire six-month project is on this
you're like whatever i can't even count
that low
and you just dismiss it like it's
useless and i'm over here thinking bro
this is my whole thing
yeah yeah and you just don't be that guy
don't care
sometimes the scale of two rivals are so
different it leads to ambiguity
for example it took many years of the
1990s for the united states to conclude
it wasn't a struggle with al qaeda
even as the competition bounced above
and below the threshold of violence
rivals often use or create ambiguity to
cloak their actions
they do this intentionally to obscure
their aims until it's too late for their
competitors
to react effectively they want to use
ambiguous
acts to cause indecision confusion
and hesitation
that is going on all the time with
people that you work with
with your wife with your husband
you know it's like oh where are you
going i'm just gonna head out
like there's all these little ambiguous
responses that happen and then the next
thing you know you look up and it's like
wait wait a second
where do we get this new car from
oh i thought i thought you said when you
needed it i didn't know anything about
that i told you i was heading out yeah i
told you i was heading out
so and i
must say ambiguous acts
are good to recognize they're also good
to utilize
in you know put that in your toolbox
and if you're a leader too you see those
words indecision confusion hesitation if
you're a leader
those those are problems those are those
are not good things for you when you
or your people are dealing with those
you gotta those are the things you have
to address and fix
and clarify
[Music]
i suppose it's like okay and then and
then things start to get away from you
and people are operating they don't know
what's going on
i like it when i catch somebody
when i catch somebody trying to throw
some ambiguity at me
and there's a lot like big words and
blah blah blah and figures
you just and you just let them do it and
then right
i when i let them do it i usually i
usually give them like a
like i give them enough time maybe even
maybe even another two three four
minutes maybe even
seven minutes of discussion about
something else and but i uh you ever see
me on
on like when i'm doing a zoom meeting
and i always have a pad right next to me
you know i don't mean writing something
down and i'll be right
um you know whatever write down a note
about what dave
said and then when he ambiguously
threw in there and then
seven minutes later he thinks he's clean
yeah thinks he's got away with it
and i go hey when you said earlier what
do you mean by this and it's such a good
thing to give them a little bit of time
because then it catches them off guard
and they're not ready for it if you ask
them immediately they're ready to
maneuver some more and if you catch them
with it
and it's fun that's funny you mentioned
that because i noticed that early on
wait long time ago
years ago and one of the things i
remember concluding that you were like
that
not so much that you liked it but that
like that was the thing if you throw
some ambiguous stuff at you like you're
gonna be like okay and then cut right
through and then ask like a direct
question
and one of the one of the situations
this is a long time ago
um there was a guy a guy came into the
gym
and just you know he's a visitor he's
like hey you know i've been training you
know i'm a jiu jitsu guy and i've been
this and you know how
a lot of like visitors might say that
kind of stuff you know like
it's almost comparable with the guy who
says i got 500 street fights you know
it's only
like that that behavior is comparable to
that and he'd like yeah you know i'm
you know i'm i forget what he said but
he he was real ambiguous about his
training but he implied that he had a
lot
and i remember thinking like oh this
this guy what he said still leaves a
huge question mark of how
experienced this person is then you're
just looking at me go what belt are you
in jiu jitsu
because like because he mentioned the
jiu jitsu right
and he let him talk and he finished his
whole spiel about his
you know experience you're like straight
up dead
dead pen what belt are you in jiu jitsu
and he was like oh well i don't have a
belt or whatever
yeah which is no offense to people that
don't have a belt because there's people
that don't have any belt in jiu jitsu
and they're awesome but there must have
been other characteristics about this
guy that let me think like
these guys are whack it totally wasn't
about that it wasn't about what
belt he was it was about he was being
ambiguous with his training and he
mentioned jiu jitsu that he had training
in jiu jitsu so you wanted to
maybe get a little bit of clarification
but it was real direct i was like oh
damn
gave him those three minutes of talking
to
think he got through with that that he
was a jujitsu guy sure
yeah yeah
some actors appear ambiguous because
they have
internal divisions multiple internal
centers of power or both
this includes national governments
reflecting the internal political
competition taking place within them
these actors often do not speak with a
single voice from the outside their
intentions can appear
confusing or conflicting this this
happens in every organization
you know you get the answer from mom
gives a different answer than dad
well and it's confusing
just as war fighting states uncertainty
is a perv oh this whole section is
called uncertainty uncertainty is a
pervasive trait of war
it is also a pervert pervasive trait of
competition
we make estimates of our competitors
designs and act accordingly
now what's been funny about this is i
talked to a lot of clients about this
what you have to do and what the marine
corps is talking about right there is
take a guess
and no one wants to hear that they even
the marine corps didn't want to use that
they say
make estimates of our competitor's
designs and act accordingly what does
that mean it means take a guess at what
you're going to do
take a guess at what they're going to do
and then take a guess at what you should
do afterwards
uncertainty in international relations
cannot be eliminated
it is non-linear meaning that a small
amount of uncertainty can have a large
effect on the situation dealing with it
means one is also dealing with risk
often a competitor's goal is to use
ambiguity to inject uncertainty
uncertainty into a situation so the
rival will hesitate to act
using it to take incremental steps
toward their ultimate goal
this approach is known as gradualism or
salami slicing
it's interesting that the marine corps
decided to throw salami slicing into
which i've never have you ever heard
that term before no
echo charles no not in this context in
any context
i mean other than making a sandwich yes
okay
yeah so we get this approach known as
gradualism or salami slicing
which is each step taken is by itself
so small it does not cause a significant
reaction from the opposing group
eventually the sum of small steps will
result in reaching the goal
actors now what's what's important about
this is look
there's two things that you should we
should be learning from
every one of these techniques
that we hear one is what do we need to
look out for and one is
what can we utilize right so yes we want
to use gradualism
like yeah echo doesn't really notice
that i'm doing this it's good to add in
a little bit
every day you know this little thing i'm
making this little adjustment
next thing you know echo looks up and
things totally changed and there's
he didn't even notice it happening
boiling the frog right the water the
the frog doesn't notice that the water's
getting hotter hotter
so we want to know to utilize that as an
as a technique as a strategy we also
need to know to look out for it
and echo's making these little
adjustments and i go hey echo that's
four days in a row you did this what's
that what are you trying to do what are
you trying to get
trying to make happen what's going on
bro
so salami slicing is literally another
expression like
for boiling yes frog like same deal at a
time
yeah actors also make use of ambiguity
and uncertainty to cause enough
hesitation so they can reach their goal
while their competitor tries to make
sense of the situation love that
love that i it's almost interesting that
the marine corps doesn't talk about
we need to utilize these things and it's
also
very interesting how two times in this
one paragraph
they talk about hesitation because
hesitation hesitation kills
hesitation is
is awaiting and reacting instead of
making things happen
and just using these techniques to get
people
off just get him to hesitate a little
bit
good move we like that move
there's also a as i as i listen to this
it's crazy how similar this is to so
many things that you have said just on
the podcast
count sometimes if you just kind of
change the view of this is
uncertainty with your opponent that if
you change the lens a little bit that
just in leadership
in general in any situation even with
your own team
i think it says something like uh what
was the quote you have to take a guess
they had some fancy word for that
guess what you don't know the future so
should we make some big massive move 50
no why don't we just
and you talk about incremental decision
making because we actually don't know
what's going on i guess that's what
salami slicing is one little step at a
time
it allows you to react to what's going
on and even how
the way you talk about that from a
leadership perspective it's not a big
stretch to go from this description of
the marine corps and a competitor to
just you in a leadership role
you don't have a crystal ball you don't
know the future don't fall in love with
your plan
just take steps just salami slicing
steps in a row and
you will actually get to where you need
to be with so much less conflict than if
you say
we have to take this giant move all the
way to the end right now go
yeah and you're what is it you're a
degree off and by the end you're 100
degrees off
yeah um my reputation for being a
decisive leader
and i cheated i cheat i ch i'm super
decisive but i cheat because i only make
little tiny decisions
but no one knows that they're just like
wow he made the decision quick it's like
oh yeah
because it's a little tiny decision with
almost no risk but we're gonna do it
immediately and then we're gonna get
feedback and then we're gonna figure out
what to do next and i'll make that
decision quickly as well
so i'm gonna make decisions very quickly
but there's little decisions and i'm
going to make them rapidly and that's
how i'm going to beat you
i guess jacob's a salami slicer
according to the breakfast
uh by the time the competitor figures it
out the goal is achieved
which is called fate accompli something
already done
little thing here called boundary
stretching
boundary or threshold stretching occurs
when an actor uses measures
short of war to force movement or change
in the nature of a boundary to gain
greater
regional influence access and control
man man as a leader you're always
dealing with people pushing that
boundary on you
right they're just sorry i was a little
bit late yeah
echo challenge just a little bit right a
little boundary stretch
maybe if two minutes is okay maybe three
minutes are good to go
what's funny is that's absolutely true
with being late
i come from a long line of late people
we all know that but
yeah like if i was one minute late and i
didn't hear about it
i'd be like okay cool one minute is kind
of the standard some
it's more subconscious but it's like
when you're running like one minute late
whatever
the next time you don't feel that stress
at all
you're like oh i was one minute late
before nothing so no problem right
then you're like a minute half two
minutes three minutes and then you kind
of like probe you know you're kind of
like wait am i gonna hear about it
no oh that's no problem then obviously
there's a there's a pretty solid
threshold of lateness that
that i can kind of exist in you know and
then when you get to 10 minutes 20
minutes late
then you start here by you say okay i
know now i know what the boundaries are
yes sir
exactly right habitual line stepper
that might be a different thing but yeah
by boundary we mean the limit of
a limit of some kind that if crossed
would normally trigger a significant
reaction
but before but before the boundary
stretching events occur most people
would assume
crossing a red line would cause a
violent response of some kind
the goal of the actor using boundary
stretching is to achieve their goals
in such a way that a response is not
triggered
or if a response happens it does not
result in a state of war between the two
actors
this is when this happens we often see a
new limit established
the boundary has been stretched you've
got to be careful this hey in a
leadership position
this you're gonna have people doing this
this is 24 7 from your troops
they're stretching those boundaries and
what you have to do is you have to be
consistent
you have to be consistent you can't
and look i'm not saying it's like no
slack
no nothing no way you're one minute late
no but if you
if you let that line stepping become
habitual it will develop into a problem
so you and the way that you this is
what's good
first of all you don't draw lines in the
sand
which i got asked a question about this
the other day like how often would you
draw a line in the sand
it's very very seldom very seldom do i
draw a line this ending
across this line you do not right
we're not doing that now is there
a border to things that if you cross
you're gonna like it's gonna be a real
problem but that's a real
significant thing so here's what we're
talking about minimum force required
minimum force required is good it's a
good way to
keep the boundary stretching in check so
if you're
if look the punishment for being late is
you know your pay is docked for a week
and you're one minute late do i
necessarily need to dock your pay
no but can i just let it go no
i give you a appropriate
response hey echo you you know what the
punishment is for being late right
because you were a minute late today and
look
that's a one week no pay you know that
right yeah i know okay i'm just making
sure because
i mean time is time and i know you come
from a long
line of people that are late but
sometimes we gotta we gotta take
ownership of that we gotta be on time
so when people start to stretch the
boundaries
you push them back you push them back in
there not with violence of action
but with the subtlest form of leadership
and the minimum force that you can to
get them back where they know that they
cross the line
and that it's not okay
so actually let me ask you this okay so
my
boss supervisor whatever when i did hear
about it
he would i see what he was trying to do
i think he was trying to do that right
the minimum
but he'd almost like giggle about it
yeah kind of like oh you're late
and i'm thinking back on my feelings
about it where
it caused me to not take it seriously
because like we were both laughing at it
kind of like yeah
so more force was required yeah he did
maybe like a twist of like just don't
giggle
about it just be like hey i agree
obviously not a huge deal but
do you remember the guy a guy i think it
was at the muster
he's like you know i'm i'm a funny guy i
like to joke around a lot
and you know i i like to crack jokes
i've always been kind of the class clown
kind of guy
and you know sometimes it seems like my
people aren't taking me seriously
and i was like bro okay do we need to go
on with this or are we just going to
stop making jokes when it's not
appropriate
how's that sound so yes it's not
appropriate if you're trying to
now listen hey what about when i joke
with you
if you're late like bro what's up
right it's like i'm gonna be honest it's
the same thing same thing
the thing is i'm not really lazy yeah i
know that's a bad example everyone
thinks you're
everyone thinks you're late now because
i talk so much smack to you yeah like
i have people on my life what about when
echoes late
well actually and i had to say this the
other day i'm like actually cause i was
like
what do you do with echo and he's late
all the time and i go actually he's not
like all the time
just kidding it's a joke yeah so guess
what what does that tell you
you're sitting here saying all the jokes
don't really affect me they do affect
you and they affect you perfectly
because you're not late because you know
that little bit of ribbing is just
enough to let you know we don't we're
not late around here
right we're not late for the podcast
yeah that's
and that's not to mention that you and
dave burke good deal dave have
effectively and successfully by the way
cultivated
an atmosphere of uh late being
a for real bad thing because on kauai
late
it's not necessarily a bad thing
i'm not saying it's a good thing but i'm
saying it's not under mo you know a lot
of circumstances like this bad thing
late it's sort of like we got other
things going on and we all kind of know
that
let's just say the culture isn't
cultivated the way it is here
we'll say that it's cultivated yes
exactly right
it says cultivated in a way where a lot
of us
make psychological mental physical
adjustments that may accommodate
these things you know when they do
happen
on a slightly more serious note if i can
ruin this for a second
there's actually another reason why when
you were talking about escalation to
counseling
why the first part of hey are you okay
hey what's going on
there's another reason why that is
especially if that is actually a thing
you actually mean that it's not like
some game you're playing you're like hey
bro
yeah well it should it better be
something it has to be right it's not
even
if you're no no if you don't mean hey
bro are you okay you were late is
everything all right if you don't mean
that you're just doing a little
manipulation okay
no you're not you're not you're not a
good leader exactly and and
that first step of that which is rather
than go right to the hey you broke the
rules here's the paper you got to sign
because you buy it with the rules it's
it's it's partially my wife's hey i'm
paying attention this is important to me
but it's my way of letting you know this
is important not because i want you to
be on time but because i want to know
what's going on
with you you now know hey dave's paying
attention to this stuff and so by me
saying hey echo man
everything cool at home isn't the mental
jujitsu of don't ever be late
it's actually you realizing this guy
actually is paying attention to my life
and cares about my life
in a in a positive way that if i got to
get to step three
you won't you don't ever want you don't
want that to happen
you don't want to put me in that spot
because you know i care about you i'm
like hey man what's going on
am i gonna get to level three and you're
now signing paperwork
i mean come on bro like what's going on
here and the starting with that
accomplishes a lot and just exactly what
you're saying was my point is if you
actually care and paying attention to
that
that other person sees that oh dude they
dave's
dave's got my best interest in mind not
like he cares about the one minute it's
not even about that it's
there's other pieces of that in the
escalation the counseling of me paying
attention to what's going on in your
world
because chances are if we're on the same
page you being late there actually
probably is some go something going on
in your world or else you wouldn't be
late
right that's so true look so this might
be
no i think this is a good example so
when i lived in honolulu i ran out
technically i ran a yellow light but it
was one of those like i pushed it
you know the kind like i had way it was
probably more appropriate to stop then
run you know you just want to
anyway so i do that get pulled over
cop's looking at me of course he
explains it to me i'm trying to play it
off like no no it was yellow all good
he's like
but he that's how he acted the way
you're talking dave
where he'd be like hey he didn't give me
give me a ticket either but he gave me a
little warning
but it was like he cared you know so he
was like he's like
i get it you know you want to you you
don't stop at the red light i get it
whatever he's like but man like i don't
want i don't want to have to give you a
ticket
you know for running red lights and i
for sure don't want any accidents
happening
and you know i don't want to be in that
spot to have to do that to you you know
as far as the ticket goes
but that's how he was talking to me and
i remember thinking bro you're so right
i'm so sorry
you know like i will i will never do it
again for for
us you know like it it was that feeling
that i got from the guy
he let me go he could have gave me a
ticket straight up and i would have been
a man i'm sorry i'll never do it again
like
that's the way he talked to me if he
gave you a ticket you would have been
angry
maybe he might have been i'm gonna run
red lights on purpose
yeah if he had a bad attitude or an
attitude that let's say i didn't like
um then yeah for sure but his attitude
was the thing that won me over of course
not getting a ticket
is a thing for sure but the way he
talked to me
it made me like we'll say it compelled
compliance in a very
nice way check
case in point you know perfect example
fluidity next section fluidity disorder
complexity while interests usually
remain stable for long periods of time
okay that's important right we
normally we focus on the same thing for
a long period of time the ways and means
groups use to reach them can't
change constantly the efforts by by
groups
to try different approaches produces
fluidity
while each action changes the
environment as well once again this is
ooda loop right
we gotta every action you take changes
the situation
actors see the new structure and adapt
to it
changes that often increase the level
dis
changes that often increase the level of
disorder
so every little move you make creates a
change and then you adapt to that it
creates another change this is
constantly happening
we change the system whenever we
interact with it often in
unpredictable ways that's the way
it goes these factors
and their constant change create a great
deal of complexity in the environment
the complexity this complexity also is
also systemic and therefore
non-linear as small changes in one
aspect of competition
can cause big impacts in other areas
because change is a constant and actors
continually adapt to changes in an
effort to achieve competitive advantages
complexity runs throughout the
competition continuum
and i read all that so i could read this
i read all of that so i could read this
marines must learn to thrive in this
environment
and i read that in order to say this
instead of trying to create
order in the vain hope of avoiding
complexity
so all the there's look things are going
to change the adaptions you make to
change is going to cause even more
change change is going to happen
randomly it's going to be complex it's
non-linear
all these things are changing and you
have to learn
how to thrive in that environment
instead of saying no
keep it the way it was just keep things
the way they were keep on that same path
we can't change we can't change
that's a vain hope
the human dimension in case all that
didn't cause enough chaos there's the
human dimension
as the nation's force in readiness once
again
the marine corps just
making sure everybody knows as the
nation's force in readiness
marines will often find themselves
involved in competitions that are
close to the threshold of violence
the threat of violence this section is
the threat of violence acts on the human
brain
in much the same way as experiencing
actual violence acts on it
the two are not synonymous because
actually experiencing violence is
clearly more coercive than the threat of
it
yet we must be aware of how the threat
of violence
affects human decision-making because
even
its threat can cause a physical and
emotional response in people
this increases the potential for
misjudgment overreaction and other
mistakes
it could also be a it could also be a
source
of competitive advantage for those who
can control their emotions
in the heat of the moment so they can
make sound decisions boom
what what
this is what's interesting here okay
obviously you got what's on the surface
which the face of it is listen even the
threat of violence can make people freak
out
violence will definitely make or can
definitely make people freak out
so you've got to realize that the threat
of violence can make people freak out
actual violence can make people freak
out here's what's interesting when you
when you throw the influence continuum
over this
me barking the order of dave you know
what dave
shut up and do what i told you to do
that creates an emotional response from
you
and it's not a good one taking away
someone's control over their destiny
taking away their ownership from them
imposing
your will onto someone creates
an emotional reaction in many cases and
by the way
if i work for dave and dave imposes his
will on me
and i allow it to make me mad i'm being
weak
um it's causing an emotional response he
had to be like okay you know what dave
is just
he can't he doesn't have a good plan and
he's forcing this plan on top of me okay
got it
i'm gonna go do the best i can with it
that's the right attitude to have
just like if someone's trying to get
violent with me
if i freak out and get emotional that's
a problem
you look confused echo charles no sir
makes sense to me
okay
detach from your emotions
now we get into this a nation's culture
and its effect on how people think
also affects the choices they make for
example
some cultures promote holistic thinking
while others
value a more analytical thought process
some value action
which can create an implicit bias toward
regularly choosing the most aggressive
course of action
the list of potential cultural
influences is a long one
thus culture will have an impact on many
aspects of competition including
decision making and how information is
perceived
understanding the human dimension of
competition is an area needing constant
study
by marines so so
hey marines and hey everyone else in the
world you better understand
human beings and human nature
that's what you need to do now you know
what i love about this
think about this team leaders
ceos business people of the world think
about this
if a nation's culture affects how you
think and the choices you make guess
what's going on inside your business
if you haven't developed the culture
that you want
to drive people to make the decisions
that you want them to make you're
letting that fly out the window you're
leaving it up to chance
to what dave thinks dave should do i
don't want dave to think about what dave
should do
i want dave to think oh yeah you know
what i know that
in this company we take care of our
clients okay got it when the client
calls up and has a complaint or wants
something or
needs something dave doesn't go away you
know what i'm off the clock right now
sorry i can't help you
no dave goes hey what do you need how
can i help you
we're here we're here to help that's
what we do
so if you run an organization or you're
part of an organization
that culture if you don't focus on that
culture
you are wasting your time you're wasting
your efforts
and not even wasting is the wrong word
you're hurting your efficiency
is what you're doing and look we talked
about this on the debrief podcast
the and i talked about it a bunch on ef
online
the highest form of decentralized
command
is culture if you have
if everyone in the organ organization
understands what the culture is
they can make decisions all day long
they can make 99.9
of decisions based on just knowing what
the culture is
and when people don't understand the
culture inside your organization
that's when they do the stuff that makes
you go what the hell was dave thinking
what was dave thinking what was that
front line
cash register individual thinking when
they did that
what was that what whatever you name it
was that frontline person
do thinking well how the hell did they
do that well that's crazy it's because
you haven't
you haven't built the culture that
guides their actions
invest in your culture build it
make it part of everything that you do
and you know what i had to answer this
question today on ef online somebody
asked me like oh
how are you doing a good job i'm not
doing a good job of building culture
what stories are you telling
what stories are you telling to the team
that's where culture
comes from by the way that's where it
comes from
is the stories that
fuel the culture stories feel the
culture of your organization
and if you want people if you want to
develop a culture you got to have the
stories to back it up
that's what the marine corps does in
such an outstanding way i got this thing
i'm going to cover on the podcast
i think the name it's a it's a field
manual
or maybe it's just a some issued thing
it's called
[Music]
it's called the squad leader makes a
difference
volume one
so you want to talk about how you
develop a culture well hey you know what
it would be nice if our scot if our if
our it would be nice if our squad
leaders really stepped up and made
things happen
oh cool i'm going to write a book it's
called the squad leader makes a
difference i'm going to highlight
historical factual things that took
place where the squad leader
saved the division saved the battalion
saved the effort
saved the mission the squad leader did
it we're going to tell everybody in the
marine corps that that's what happened
and guess what that new squad leader is
going to think he's going to think i'm
going to make a difference
i'm important my decision and this is
the truth
so that's what the marine corps does
they do it
they do it just in such an impeccable
way
and really good companies do that well
really good companies they tell that
story inside the company so everybody
knows
what that company is they get that
culture
so if you want to be build culture you
better invest
in telling the story capturing the story
telling the story
that's what you need to do
the squad leader makes a difference i
might have to do that one very such a
cool
that's such a perfect such a perfect
example of how you build culture
you tell mythical they're not mythical
they're historical
next the art science and dynamic
of competition the art science and
dynamic of competition
the marine corps as part of the joint
force
plays an essential role in securing
national aims and conditions sometimes
regarded as outside the military spear
sphere competition below the threshold
of armed conflict
and often the lengthy consolidation of
gains
that inevitably follows war
to play this role successfully marines
need the ability to see and understand
the competitive forces in the
environment
understand what tools are available to
them and be able to envision
how they can contribute to a campaign
of competition
the marines have to understand how
they're gonna
contribute to a campaign of competition
that takes place through this entire
continuum
and then the next sentence is creativity
or
art is necessary to imagine different
ways and means for marines to contribute
to contribute
to reaching these aims again what's the
focus in the united states marine corps
apparently creativity and art
constructing a set of steps along a
timeline
to help reach them along with the
necessary feedback loops to improve
performance over time
are abilities that align with the
science of completion of competition
in many ways this is nothing new
and then they break it down it comes
down to sizing up your opponent
with a critical eye and then coming up
with a creative solution that allows you
to achieve your goal despite the
opponent's resistance
marines have done this for ages
and i think ages is a strong word i
don't i i we have to look i didn't look
it up but the definition of ages to me
means longer than how old is the marine
corps 240 years
yeah 245 years 245 years
ages yeah seems a little bit bigger but
you know what the marines is going to
put that in your head you know why
they're telling the story
they're developing the culture that as
long as time has existed
marines have used art and creativity to
figure out how to
size up their opponent and crush them
yeah and you want to be you want to be
in on that
you want to be part of that yeah i'm in
i mean this is this whole
there's so many things inside here so
crazy i was thinking of just the idea of
of as a leader the power of culture i
mean you could look at on this
very tiny little selfish level of
the stronger that culture is if you're
in a leadership the more free time you
have
the more things will happen without you
having to get involved in those things
and that free time
obviously is not so you can do nothing
and so you can think about
other more long-range more strategic
things and then these telling these guys
carrying a rifle or flying an airplane
that's not enough
that's not what you're doing and that
seemingly insignificant little micro
task of one of
hundreds of thousands of marines you
just
the squad leaders the squad leader is a
corporal
it's a corporal rifleman with with a
couple other
corporals working for him i mean on
paper it seems so small and so
insignificant
but it's not it's huge and as a leader
do you want people at that level in
organization
thinking the entire weight of the
organization rests on their shoulders
yes because that's what guides them to
make those decisions so you don't have
to do it
it's it's there's so much in there man
and and it echoes so many of the things
that you talk about
and it's just a very slight variation of
this competition with other other armies
but
it's all the same thing as a leader it's
the exact same thing
and that's why i started off in the
opening of this podcast by saying that
if you
know the way broadly you see it in all
things so good man
the nature of these campaigns will
require marines to get comfortable
asking for authorities
to use tools in new domains like cyber
or support to public
diplomacy these campaigns combine
cooperation and competition
with other dime instruments of power
including armed conflict if necessary to
achieve and sustain
strategic objectives dime and i don't
even know if people say that the way is
d-i-m-e
it means diplomatic information military
and economic so so
we have to be able to work in all those
domains diplomatic
information military that's the obvious
one and then economic we're playing a
role in all those things
the evolution of competition next
section
international competition is never
static it constantly evolves
in fact it is co-evolutionary because as
one actor develops a competitive tool
other actors adapt to it by trying to
either counter it or develop another
tool that displaces it
this co-evolution is seen clearly when
technology changes
and once again guess what they use here
for an example do they use
a military battle do they use no they
don't use that they use henry ford
henry ford's invention of the assembly
line caused dramatic
efforts to adapt among other automakers
in today's world firms increasingly try
to automate their assembly lines in an
effort to stay ahead
in the competitive marketplace in much
the same way
the choices political actors make in
developing new concepts and technology
to support them are competitive acts
they develop them because they seek an
advantage over a particular
rival or rivals so look the battlefield
changes all the time
the market changes all the time your
competitors are doing things to adapt to
that you have to do things to adapt to
what their adaptations are
this is what does it say never static
it's never static
i used to tell the the young seals out
in the field during training exercises
with big fire fight would break out with
paintball
and all of a sudden it would go quiet
and the tendency was oh
cool they're not shooting at us we can
rest and i'd
go over and whisper in the leader's ear
and i'd say
hey when you're not getting shot at it
means the enemy is maneuvering on you
never static what can you do how can you
improve your position right now
the speed of this evolution usually
rests on the rate of technological
change because new technologies create
opportunities to develop concepts new
concepts
or new concepts may stimulate the
development of new technology
in some cases though new concepts emerge
when mature technologies are combined
with new organizations and new operating
methods
as militaries wrestle with the questions
of how to build and keep an edge over
their potential opponents
they juggle factors like switching costs
which is
how much money and effort does it take
to make make a change
that's a good term switching costs so
how much money is going to take us
to make a change and how much effort is
it going to take that's a switching cost
the cost curve will i spend more or less
than my opponent
how long can i sustain this level of
spending the level of spending that this
change requires that's a cost curve and
then opportunity cost which i think most
people know
if i put and this is the marine corps
explaining it if i put effort into this
change
then i will not be able to do something
else instead so we always have to weigh
the opportunity cost
if i focus on this thing over here that
means i'm not focusing on some other
thing over here what's that what's that
going to mean
marines know that in combat sometimes we
fight to gain
information about the enemy once we
obtain this information
we then inject into we then inject it
into our plan so that we can increase
the effectiveness of our operation
so we're constantly out trying to figure
out what the enemy's doing trying to
gain information on them
once we gain information we inject it
into our plans
so we can be more effective the same
dynamic exists
in competition clearly
we gain information as we compete with a
rival and must use this to our advantage
here's what i think we got to remember
about this
sometimes we're gaining information well
oftentimes
a great way to gain information is to
proactively probe
for it you know what's what's what's
echo's base like i'll try a little sweep
oh
got some good bass oh but he exposes his
arms sometimes oh that's good to know
little information i tried a little
something learned some information
we're constantly doing that
war fighting teaches that that's the
book warfighting teaches
that we should try to get inside the
enemy's thought processes
and see the enemy
as they see themselves
that's why that's why
colonel david hackworth had his troopers
read
mouse tongue to figure out what they
were thinking
how they're going to fight this war he
explains mao explains how to fight the
guerrilla war
why would you not be studying that why
would you not be trying to get inside
the
the enemy's head
this holds equally for getting inside
our competitors
thought processes
so we should be doing the same thing and
not just about war what are you thinking
and this goes back to this one that one
i've been
it's funny how everything ties together
cause uh daryl and i
did uh an unraveling podcast and the
title of podcast was what's your story
and just about how we
create stories in our heads
and they're very malleable you can be
very easily influenced and you
you go through it's a it's almost like a
survival mechanism to create a story
inside your head so that you can
comprehend
the world and we do that and there's all
kinds of
psychological experiments that we talk
about on that on that particular podcast
that proves that you'll just kind of
make things up like if there's not a
good explanation you'll be like well
hey that's what happened and you'll
believe it and so we're doing that all
the time
we're doing that we're telling ourselves
little stories so it's important
and i've been saying this on ef online
as well it's
one thing for me to try and understand
dave's perspective
well you know dave's in that division
over here and they've got this as a
priority
so his perspective must be this that's
great that's a great that's a great
thing to do please understand people's
perspective
let's go deeper though what i really
want to do is i want to know what's
dave's
story what where where where's he come
from
what's his background how long has he
been here who's he worked for
who's he got on his team what's his
family doing what's his family situation
what's his financial situation where is
he at
what is his story
you ever you ever like you're with your
buddy and you know echo and i are
hanging out and then
dave comes over and echo's never met
echo before and hey dave what's up how's
it going boom and then dave leaves and
echo goes what's that guy's
story you see what i'm saying
definitely we want to know what people's
stories are and if we can
understand what someone's story is then
we can better predict what they're going
to do not just their perspective
look their perspective will be part of
the story you can understand their story
you understand their perspective
now i can do a much better job of
predicting not with 100 accuracy
but with more accuracy so i can make a
better guess
a better anticipation of what their move
is going to be
so we are always trying to get inside
our competitors thought process
trying to know what their story is
powerful tool
and then we get into this conclusion
competition is the normal state of the
relationship
between political actors in
international relations
right and obviously it's not just that
it's between human beings there's
competition happening
echo you always talk about that thing
where you like you're like when i see
someone
kind of sizing them up like you've
talked about this in jiu jitsu where you
say
basically if someone that's an
equivalent kind of height weight
age scenario as you yeah what's your
what's your thoughts
you're sizing them up there's
competition but we we don't even know
this person
this person may not even train they
might not even care right but you're
looking at them like
you're in the game you you said that
real
like in passing they're like they might
not even care
my hypothesis is that they do care
in one way or another a physical
situational evaluation takes place when
you meet someone
within that realm or whatever some kind
of thing
not to say you want to beat them up not
to say you want to fight with them not
to say you want to
whatever i'm just saying that evaluation
process is a real thing
and it happens i think most of the time
again
if a guy's so far out of the scope of
like your
we'll see your orbit right we'll call it
for lack of a better term
like your age your size if it's a
jiu-jitsu
situation or whatever then yeah it kind
of it kind of doesn't happen that much
but
yes i still believe that dave
when you were in the united states
marine corps
and you met someone that was also
a fighter pilot what's the thought
process
i mean totally man for sure hey how can
you
how can you what's the what's the what's
the pecking order
if we haven't got to dog fight against
each other how does that work
i mean you know at the most basic level
is what's that guy fly
you know and you can in your mind and
and wait meaning
oh is this guy flying f-18 like i fly
harriers
you you know and and i'm not
defending this train of thought but you
will draw some conclusions in your mind
right and backtrack you'll create his
story for him in your own head like oh
jacquel flezas okay well this happened
this happened this happened this
happened
and you'll trace it back to him when
he's five and got him all figured out
because you're sizing them up a little
bit and
you'll you'll create and the more
similar
the scenario is the more
i guess the more friction could be there
in your mind i'm like oh this guy
interesting okay this this could be this
could be a thing we might you know we
might have to
we don't have to figure this out you
know up in the air
so just the way you described it i mean
it's it's very similar do you figure it
out in the air
i mean that's the easiest way to do it
can you i mean is it is it like
because one thing that's great about jiu
jitsu oh i'm sizing this guy up
yeah hey wanna roll we're about to find
out
we're about to find out yeah can you do
that you can but you can see in a whole
you can how does this guy brief how does
this guy get along
you know when he first shows up at a
squadron how does he do other types of
flying
uh there's a bunch of different ways it
doesn't just have to be you
and one other person in a dogfight but
especially at top gun what's cool is
you get to do that a lot and that's
probably the most fun way to just
i don't know when i say settle it
because this you know
that sounds pretty crazy but you you can
create
you can resolve a lot of things by doing
that we'll say it helps establish
it does it in the hierarchy it it
absolutely does you know and and
if that's if that's all you go on then
you're going to create problems by doing
that but there is a hierarchy there is a
hierarchy in there
and it is always better to be towards
the top of that hierarchy
that's a better place to be than at the
bottom of it how often
is a guy a freaking awesome pilot and
just a
turd leader not very often
most of the time yeah it can't happen
most of the time usually
there's a there's a correlation and as a
matter of fact
you know i'd rather have a guy who's
who's an awesome leader he's a great
person to be around a great teacher
and it's kind of a top third than a dude
who's
you know just really good at flying an
airplane and he sucks at everything else
and so
you know the hierarchy is not just who
won in that particular fight there's a
whole bunch of things but
it's i think it's the same very similar
yeah and the higher
argues not just that but let's face it
right yeah i mean the culture the
hierarchy of a culture is kind of like
people understand it even though it
might not be able to be
like 100 percent tangible you know you
kind of like injured
i'm sure it's like that as well in
flying and all
other activities i always like telling
these stories though because i know jack
is over there thinking
i don't like to rely on machines and
he's in the whole day like whatever it's
a machine
i don't care oh your machine can beat my
machine
cool well the other thing that's also
from a leadership perspective
is you got to recognize that inside your
team when you've got 12 people working
for you there's competition going on
between those two people
and the little subtle the little subtle
preferences or statements or comments
that you make
impact that competition and can create
animosity
where you should be as a leader trying
to unify your team
so so pay attention to that competition
look and and then there's times where we
want to
seed and fuel competition right oh yeah
echo versus hey who's a better shot you
or you were dave and it's oh i'm better
okay
let's see and now we're creating some
stress so that we get better training
it's great so we want to fuel that
but we don't want to have a negative
impact we don't want to take away from
the team
by fueling competition competition just
like anything else guess what there's a
dichotomy
you can go too far with competition now
we got the team attacking each other
but if we don't have any competition now
the team's not staying sharp
yeah and we see this all the time i mean
i think in my mind like the simplest
example is when we work with companies
and we talk about their sales
departments
there's there's absolute competition
among sales and do we want that
yeah absolutely i want sales teams
pushing each other
uh and so the connection from this
this publication about you know
competing the recognition like you said
that exists
everywhere and what a good leader does
is actually harness that so
everybody benefits and wins from that is
critical and if you don't think that's
going on
as a leader if you're like oh no we're
all just harmonious we're all just fully
aligned on the same page all the time
and there's no competition here
you're missing a whole bunch of those
dynamics there's a lot of power in that
and if you're not paying attention to it
that can spiral out of control and you
get this
you get this friction to the point that
people on the same team are actually
sabotaging each other yeah
oh i'm not giving dave my lead because
i'm not turning this over i'm not going
to give him the back brief on what that
client's like because i don't want him
to get another
mark on the board
so once again conclusion competition is
the normal state of the relationships
between political actors
in international relations it occurs as
the interests
of these actors come into conflict as
they try and advance them in the world
right everyone's working on their own
little gig oftentimes
two political actors will compete in one
area and cooperate in another
thus there is a competition continuum
that extends from
relatively benign efforts to advance
interest to the violent efforts that
include
war war then is a special kind of
competition they just can't get away
from that statement
one that sets the conditions for the
mostly nine
non-violent struggle that always follows
the row
the end of armed conflict
like war and again this is all just the
conclusion like war
this is by the way this is the
conclusion of chapter one
like war competition is characterized by
ambiguity uncertainty fluidity disorder
and complexity
rivals will try to use these attributes
to obscure their aims and achieve their
advantages over opponents competitors
naturally apply
creativity and science to develop
advantages as well
which causes the form of competition to
constantly evolve
the history of competition is also a
history of change
marine marines and the marine corps have
an important but supporting role
in the nation's competitions the
activities of marines take place
all along the continuum including on
both
sides of the violence threshold the
competition continuum
is therefore something marines must
understand and that continuum
if you if you take that idea of this
continuum and you
also then overlay the idea of leading
and the idea of influence
there's also a continuum i sort of talk
about it the escalation of counseling
it's a very similar thing
the escalation of counseling is how much
influence what are you doing to
influence
how are you doing this how are you
making this happen at what point do you
cross the threshold
from indirect to direct
minimizing the amount of time that you
spend on the direct
influence the the the coercion the
forcefulness that's not what we're
looking to do
very important stuff to think about and
with that
we i mean we i figured we could make it
through two chapters
but i don't want to jump into the next
chapter because we'll be in here
for another three hours
so with that we will we will pick up the
rest of this i guess on the next
on the next one
and you know i i got asked a question
the other day is on ef online and the
question was basically
how do i train the leadership principles
you know the leadership principles that
we teach
how do i train those leadership
principles persons ask me how do i get
better at these leadership principles
if i'm working all the time in a
leadership position in other words i'm
leading how do i have time to train how
do i have time to get better
and i
i answered the question i said listen
here's the answer
and i'm not going to get it exact but
there's two components to it
one of them is being intentional about
what you're going to do
right paying attention and in tension
those are the two words i use paying
attention and then having intention
you need to pay attention to what's
going on around you
because there's no better way to train
leadership than leading
but it only works if you
pay attention to it and then the
intention part comes from i said listen
you're going into a meeting you're going
to counsel someone
you're going to meet with your
supervisor or you're going to meet with
a subordinate
or you're going to present or whatever
you're going to do from a leadership
perspective
take three minutes before three minutes
hey i know we're all pressed for time
you can take three minutes
take three minutes and figure out
what is your intention from a leadership
perspective going into this meeting
write them down like what are you going
to do in this meeting hey um
i'm gonna i'm gonna meet with dave and
it's a subject that we disagree on
dave wants to meet with me about some
this is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
detach
i'm gonna listen i'm gonna find some
common ground
and i'm gonna ask for some time to think
about his perspective
that that's what i'm gonna do write that
down takes three minutes three minutes
to figure out what a good course of
action is
then you then you go then you go to the
meeting so that's your training
your initial part of the training is
intention what do you intend to do
boom then you go to the meeting so
that's
that's the intention part now how do you
now you got to pay attention to how you
actually did
you got to detach a little bit will you
get done with the meeting how did you do
did you get emotional did you talk
more than you listened which by the way
to me if i have a meeting where i talk
more than i listen it probably was a bad
meeting
did i lose my temper did i tell dave
there's no way we're doing it your way
right
is that where i went and you got to be
honest with yourself
and then you got to make adjustments and
that's how you're going to improve
and that's why one of the reasons that
i'm saying this is that
these manuals they can be so helpful to
us
and for us because we they can they can
they can tell us what it is we should be
doing so we can actually do it
and and this is a subject i talked about
on ef online today
i heard this interview with uh gary
kasparov who's a
20-year chess champion and he was
talking about chess and he got asked
about magnus carlson who's this
young well he was 19 when he won the
world champion and became the best in
the world and total dominant prodigy
in the game and and the guy
basically said you know well who kind of
who's better and he didn't come right
out and say it but it was implied and
and
and gary kasparov understood the
implication
and there was a couple things that he
said one one thing he said that was
interesting he said
basically he said i'm too old to compete
which is interesting because you think
about maybe in jiu jitsu you can get too
old to compete but chess
you should get better but he talked
about the physical fitness
aspect of even playing chess and how
sharp your mind is and that tied into
how sharp your body is and if you're
younger you have an advantage which was
very
i didn't expect that at all but more
important
he said that magnus
even though he's been playing chess for
much shorter time he's only 30 years old
and
kasparov is 57 he's been playing chess
for way less time
but magnus has been able to learn
everything that
kasparov has done throughout his whole
career because they take
when when a chess game happens they
document every single move and they
they put it in a book and you can read
that book and you can know exactly what
the move was what the outcome was
and so magnus got to study those
he got to study those things he got
lifted up on the shoulders of kasparov
so how could
how could kasparov compete because it
wasn't
magnus just didn't just get to study
kasparov you got to study all the
all the masters of all time and
kasparov who dominated for 20 freaking
straight years
and i was talking about this with you
dave the other day i'm like hey dave i'm
reading a book right now
and this guy's giving information
about leadership and this is he's given
information about leadership that i
thought i kind of figured out from and i
had to figure out for myself
and he's giving information and the book
was published in 1973
and i never got to stand on the
shoulders of that giant to learn that
lesson
why because i didn't approach it with
the right attitude
so these books these documents
whether historical documents whether
it's a first person account of what
happened in battle and what that leader
did
we have to understand
that we can take those things and we can
learn from them we can literally take
moves just like moves on a chess board
and we can be a better leader
because we understand how things
occurred in the past
we get to study leadership we get to
study human nature we get to study
interactions between people when they
fight
when they go to war when they lead when
they influence
when they compete
and that paying attention
and having intention and recognizing
that
everything you see is an opportunity for
you to learn and take and put that in
your playbook
and make you better
and we miss that opportunity all the
time
because we're not paying attention and
we don't have the right intention
dude i mean god there's so
there's so much there and i think my
favorite part
about even just this first chapter
because i had a tiny suspicion like
we're never going to get through this
um how easy it was
to connect all those comments all the
things they're saying
to so many other areas so many other
places in life and you started it i
and that's saying when you when you when
you know the way broadly you see it in
all things
as as much as that as much as you say
that it's it's
so true it's such an important
so just hearing that and and and you
come out of the gate and in
three minutes you're talking about
parenting and kids and family on a on a
manual about
you know total war competition between
nation states and inside that is
all these these these these pieces of
leadership of human nature
and yeah i probably should just i can
stop at this point because
i get so fired up thinking about how
much is in there and then i think
then i think i look back on my 40 coming
up on 40 something 49 years like
man how much have i missed how many
opportunities have been out there to not
see these things at other places
uh so there's so much in there um yeah
chapter one making us better echo
charles
speaking of getting better what
suggestions do you have for us uh
well to be honest
you covered it or a big part of it i say
to be honest with you but sure i can add
maybe
hopefully hopefully i can add a little
a little something you did mention
physical fitness in chess
which was interesting that is
interesting you burn 3x the number of
calories you would normally
burn in a day so if you had a day of
just normal activity
or you did a chest tournament chest
tournament 3x
the number of calories really heart rate
goes up
breathing goes up yeah tense muscles
yeah i wonder why i wonder why like just
the stress of the company the stress of
the calm
thinking yeah yeah i was wondering how
much it was just brain
power getting used i don't know the
answer to that huh
dang and it's like you know you
mentioned muscles
tensing up but bruh okay yeah okay
but yeah right right you know okay we
really can't just throw out
you know that that's the significant you
know like all right we'll go do a metcon
for how long is the chess
match you'd say i don't know tournament
depends what type of chess
match it is yeah different types so if
you get okay there's
blitz chess yeah then there's just some
kind of timed chest and then there's
speed chess yeah i don't know if it's
called speeches yeah
okay all right well let's think
scientifically then
okay you got one booth i don't know
booth
of two guys playing chess this is gonna
last two hours
you got another booth a guy doing your
everyday run-of-the-mill metcon
for two hours well the metcon guy is
obviously burning a lot more so the
mecha
guy's gonna burn all literally all his
calories before the ch
so i'm just saying the muscle tense
thing may not be
that as much of a thing we'll say all
right speaking of
physically not recommending chess as
your new physical workout
it's not what i'm doing here okay yeah
that that seems
seems correct for sure nonetheless as
far as fitness goes look
it's not to say that chess is
like not a way to get better because
it's straight up is
but as far as physical fitness goes
maybe not but
fitness not the best avenue yeah
many other avenues jujitsu that's one of
them
just general workouts right workouts
there's all kinds of workouts whatever
um nonetheless you do have to work out i
think
i concur dave burke same
concur all right well we're working out
every once in a while
we might have issues that we that
concern us
joint issues lower back issues depending
on who you are
um a shoulder is your elbow issues as
the case may or may not be
but we don't want to worry about this
kind of issue so we got some
supplementation for we're for a lot of
stuff
really but as far as joints and stuff we
got joint warfare
we got super cruel oil we also have
vitamin d for immune i don't even want
to say issues i want to say your whole
immune situation
really to prevent issues
check this out here's i gotta uh uh wait
i gotta some good news for everybody
look there's plenty of bad news out
there in the world right now
i understand right i got some good news
for everybody here's the good news
all these different type of supplements
that you're talking about
things that i take every single day
joint warfare i take
every single day krill take every single
day discipline take every single day
vitamin d three take every single day
cold war take
every single day every single day i take
this stuff
check this out molk
yes i can't say i take it every day but
i take it six days
no five days out of seven maybe six days
out of them i have a lot of mold
yeah any of these items that you want
if you want to get them you can get them
from origin main.com and when you get
them
if you subscribe to them meaning if you
just
get a subscription for joint warfare you
get a subscription for krill oil
you will get free shipping yeah look
we because listen there's there's people
out there
rightfully so that
don't necessarily want to support some
of the
companies that sell our products for
whatever reason
but some of those companies have free
shipping which makes it real
you know it can you can save a lot of
money
so in order to take care of everyone
if you want to
subscribe to this stuff any of it if you
subscribe to one thing you'll get free
shipping on whatever you order
so so come subscribe also you give like
10 off if you subscribe so subscription
what i'm saying is if you want this
stuff and you take it all the time
like i do like echo does dave what do
you take every day
the list is the list uh i'm probably
like
i'm probably maybe maybe four or five
uh mulcs a week i'm i'm
i'm over the threshold on on discipline
go so
whatever eight out of seven if that's a
math problem um
and then i'll the only thing i will say
is that cold war had has kind of moved
to the top of my
like i never forget cold war ever and
i'm probably benefici
benefit because i have a subscription i
get it i'm going to think about it
i don't run out but look man lately
that's been off that's
i don't ever miss it ever so so
if you want to support yeah you're very
good way to support
that one support the whole situation
subscribe get free shipping save money
we're here to hook it up you're
supporting yourself by the way yeah and
you're supporting yourself
you're supporting yourself that's kind
of the original tag line
wasn't it echo charles yes sir support
yourself i steal that
as you support us you can also get the
stuff at vitamin chop
you can also get the stuff at well you
can get discipline go at wawa and by the
way
you can get it they're they're infusing
it
into every wawa on the east coast as we
speak right now
that's not in every store yet but yeah
look january 4th they started
infusing it january 4th 2020 is the day
that everyone will remember
21 21 sorry january 4th
2021 is the day that wawa
started to infuse discipline go into all
their
stores so appreciate the support
at wawa we appreciate the support from
wawa yeah
yeah it's uh yeah that's a good
situation where
let's let's face it sometimes
we don't want to order online seems
crazy well sometimes we're driving
exactly
i want my discipline go between right
now and when i get home
that's what i wanted and currently
there's none at my house you can't order
that ordering it from origenmaine.com
subscription or not is not going to help
you
in that particular one it doesn't work
that way exactly you need a wawa yes sir
you do um so yeah just we go boom
there's also discipline the powder
and the capsule yep if that's your
preferred method
you know the cans are kind of a thing
let's face it so i'm kind of i'm kind of
doing those a lot but
discipline go the powder that's a daily
for me as well
especially if i'm working out 100 guaran
so yes these things will help us in our
developmental journey
on this path to stay in the game yeah
even on the path the path uh it'll make
you better as it were
also origin main speaking origin main
dot com
as far as dot com goes uh jiu jitsu
stuff on there some good american made
stuff by the way
100 american-made jesus stuff
american denim and boots
jeans you might want to get a pair of
american-made jeans
yeah made here where's the oh but you
think oh but where's the
cotton from oh the cotton's from here
wait where was it woven oh it's woven
here
oh who died oh it's died here in america
wait what about the threat well that's
american
yeah uh what about the rivets certainly
it must be oh those rivets are from
america
yeah what about the buttons the buttons
yeah
those yeah where do we get those oh we
got them in america okay
and then who took all that stuff and put
it together into something you can cover
your legs with
you cut for your legs yeah guess guess
where guess where that happened
in america dig it yep from top to bottom
supports the podcast
support yourself and
america america it's true also speaking
of support
jocko has a store it's called jacko's
store so you go to jacquelinestore.com
this is where you can get your
discipline equals freedom
shirts hoodies hats all that stuff so
represent on the pla
path you want to get these things
jacobstort.com we have a subscription
thing too working on the name it's like
a t-shirt club
oh no i got i got the name something
from a from a
supporter and i think well i have a
i have a candidate for the name that i
think is good to go all right later
or are we there we are we disclosing
i'll just close it right now
is it because i have one two yes i'll
tell you i'll leave it in your okay you
tell me you're first
uh echo layers okay
don't like it appreciate it get it i
like
okay okay here's what about this
the shirt locker oh
bought and sold you're good all right so
officially there you go
the jocko shirt locker so now you can
yeah there we go yeah okay
all right i to be honest i was expecting
your club
all right t-shirt club slime shirt
locker okay approved approved straight
up
okay short locker kind of same deal free
shipping you know subscription you know
it's a different approach
really it's not so you don't run out of
shirts it's not that it's just you know
it's
it's a t-shirt locker anyway check that
out it's cool a little bit different
designs
for for us that are you know in the game
nonetheless
spot don't forget to subscribe to this
podcast and and also on top of this
podcast
you can join us in the jocko underground
jacounderground.com we have
an alternative podcast it's it's a
it's a podcast with amplifying in
information
to to this podcast sort of some behind
the scenes stuff
some some q a stuff some
some things that didn't quite fit the
mold yeah of jack-o-pockets let's face
it i didn't want the jogger podcast to
say
what it is yeah someone puts in their
headphones i want them to get what they
expect i want to deliver that product
that information so
however art and creativity what do we
learn from the marine corps you can't
just keep doing the same thing
so i like to get a little bit artistic
and creative
you want to do some different things so
now we have a way to do that
it's jocko underground.com
and yeah and there's look there's censor
censorship things happening right now we
want to at least be ready in case
something crazy
happens we also don't want to take on
sponsors because we don't want to start
off every podcast by saying
welcome to jocko podcast this podcast is
brought to you by
i don't want to do that and i also don't
want to in the middle of the podcast
talking about the korean war and some
fire fight and be like
and this podcast was brought no we're
not doing that so
if you want to help out if you want to
join the jocko underground
jockowinderoutground.com go there it
costs eight dollars and 18 cents a month
which is a number that has layers
i didn't even know how many layers that
number has there's so many layers
there's so many layers we're getting
layers on layers so
if you want to if you want to support
that's one way to do it
that way we we make sure we can keep
this podcast up and running no matter
what happens
if you hey look and if if you can't
afford that if you're tight on money
that's okay we we still want to have you
in the game with us email
assistance at jockowunderground.com
and and we'll have you taken care of but
if you can afford to support that's
awesome too
eight dollars and 18 cents a month also
we have the jocko unraveling podcast
which is me and dale
daryl cooper we have the grounded and
the warrior kid podcast
which i am severely delinquent on it's
lingering in the winds
yeah my daughter my youngest daughter
today was
harassing me about the warrior kit
podcast that's where it starts to hurt
she lives with uncle jake and she wants
that podcast so
i apologize i got one more book due
january 31st a book like the get your
writing
straight up and so when that book is
done we're going to make this happen
so um yeah subscribe to those as well we
got a youtube channel if you want to see
echo's videos
and more important than seeing echo's
videos it's important to understand who
the
assistant director is on many of those
videos and that's me
yeah so if you like the videos it's
probably because the assassin assistant
directing was strong
if you don't like them it's probably one
i wasn't working on and echo screwed it
up
i'm over here doing the best i can
anyway
thank you for that by the way uh also
psychological warfare
it's a uh an mp3 album with tracks of
jocko letting you know hey
don't skip this workout right because
you know when you want to skip the
workout
dave doesn't know why because he doesn't
work out or he
doesn't skip the workout he's
disciplined right he's getting it done
is that factually true my wife will not
i will not hear the end of it i will not
hear the end of it so i have some
motivation
just to not put up with the harassment
we need to make an album with
your wife yeah trying to say your will
your wife is the psychological warfare
the worst day in the brook household is
when i don't work out and she does
that's
like there's enough motivation there to
make sure that doesn't happen very often
perfect and that's kind of like a little
example because what i like about that
is like
hey it doesn't matter you worked from
four o'clock in the morning until
whenever
it's like oh it didn't work out today
did you don't care skipped it
doesn't care about it you know well for
those of us who do
entertain the notion of skipping a
workout you know just fudging on the
diet i like
all that kind of stuff which isn't
psychological warfare and i'll get you
through 100 like a little spot get it
you know amazon wherever you buy
mp3s that's where you can get it also
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer
he's making all kinds of cool stuff for
you to hang on your wall we got a bunch
of books
about face by hackworth i wrote the
forward to the new version of that
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
we got the code the evaluation the
protocols we got discipline equals
freedom field manual brand new version
we got way of the warrior kid for field
manual
how the kids liking that dave dude book
was awesome
like immediately uh supplanted all the
other ones and now it's just in the
cycle
my son that was he's just super stoked
on that one outstanding to hear
uh also weigh the warrior kid one two
and three mike in the dragon dragons
extreme ownership and the dichotomy
leadership
we got echelon front you heard us when
when dave and i are talking about
oh a client or talking to one of our
clients
that's because we have a leadership
consulting company and we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com
for details there and we have ef online
you also heard us
refer to that a bunch today it's
leadership training online
there's question and answer sessions
there's actual courses you can take
about leadership that cover these
subjects
really granular in detail
so check out efonline.com if you want
we got the muster in 2021. look that is
a
shifting target right now go to
extremeownership.com if you want to come
to a muster it's our it's our leadership
event
we have ef overwatch where we have
executive leadership for your company go
to efoverwatch.com
and if you want to help service members
if you want to help active duty
and retired families members
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization if you want to if you want
to donate or you want to get involved
go to america's mightywarriors.org
if you didn't quite get enough of my
annoying anecdotes or you need
more of echo's labyrinthine lectures or
more of dave's devoted diatribes you can
find us
on the interwebs on twitter on instagram
which echo will only and strictly refer
to
as the gram
and on facebook dave is that david r
burke echo is at echo charles and i am
at jocko willink and to
all the military folks out there and all
the branches of service
the army the navy the air force the
coast guard and yes a little extra
credit to the marine corps today
thank you all for continually competing
with forces of darkness and evil in the
world
and thanks also to police law
enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders thank you for
keeping us safe
when we call on you in our worst
moments and to everyone else out there
you are competing all the time
know that pay attention to it
pay attention to it so you can learn and
you can get better
and you can be better and you can make
the things
in your world a little bit better
a little bit better for you
and for the people around you and you do
that
by going out there every single day
and getting after it and until next time
this is dave and echo and jocko
out